This is the brief on a recent
Dungeons and Dragons session,
covering a wild rescue, a
resurrection, and a pretty hasty
retreat.
So picture this.
The adventurers are hightailing
it out of a town that just had a
coup, right?
They're carrying their dead
cleric Traxador, and their only
hope is this powerful but
frankly kind of creepy celestial
being.
First, their escape from the
town Valachi.
It only worked because the
famous Monster Hunter Rudolph
Van Richten showed up out of
nowhere.
See, after they snatched
Traxador's body back, this nasty
barbed devil came after them.
But Van Richten poof, eliminated
it instantly with a powerful
spell.
Then he gives them his hidden
wagon to escape in.
But wouldn't you know it, the
axle brakes hitting the gate.
Luckily, Van Richten magic it
back together with a quick
mending spell, and off they went
to Kresk.
Second, Traxidor actually gets
brought back to life.
The Abbot, this celestial guy
who's basically a fallen Angel
living in an Abbey, did the
honors.
He only agreed because the party
brought him a wedding dress he
wanted for Vasilka, His
disturbing flesh.
Gollum creation.
Traxidor's back.
Yeah, but the whole thing really
upset the town's leader, Dmitry
Kreskov.
He was literally weeping in the
street, yelling about how the
Abbot could save a stranger but
not his own son.
Pretty rough.
Finally, the party checks out
this old Manor.
Argon Vostolt looked promising,
right?
Dragon statue, Old Chapel.
Well inside.
Three figures in rusty armor
turned out to be revenants.
These aren't your average
undead.
They're super tough and driven
by vengeance.
It forced an immediate fighting
retreat, especially when the
Ranger Orihorn realized, hey,
even if we beat them, their
spirits just hop into new
bodies.
Yikes.
So despite getting their cleric
back, the party quickly learned
they're now up against threats
way scarier than plain old
skeletons.
Welcome to the debate.
Our focus today is Argen
Vostholt, that sprawling, really
decrepit Manor house the party
stumbled upon after well, after
that harrowing flight from
Valaki, and, of course, the
critical resurrection of
Traxador back in Kresk.
In this place, Argenvoss told.
It really presents one of the
sharpest contradictions in the
material.
I think as soon as the party
enters, they see these
incredibly powerful symbols of
good.
You've got the huge statue of a
silver dragon, you know,
typically champions of good.
And then there's the altar with
the rising sun, the symbol of
the morning Lord, right?
But these symbols are standing
amidst total ruin, physical
decay, spiritual decay, and
guarded by these, well,
incredibly dangerous undead.
Exactly.
And that paradox presents a
fundamental question for us,
really Does the presence of
these powerful undead, the self
renewing revenants within Arjun
Vos told, signify a complete
total spiritual corruption, a
collapse of the ideals that were
once held there?
Or does the fact that the
iconography, the symbols, still
persist, does that represent
something more like a tragic
state of failed duty, a sort of
lasting, maybe twisted fidelity
to those old ideals?
I really think we have to lean
towards that second
interpretation.
You know, if the place was just
purely evil, totally conquered,
why would the symbols still be
there?
It doesn't quite track.
See, I take a different view.
I see Arjun Vos told as pretty
undeniable evidence that even,
you know, really strong sources
of good can be fundamentally
tainted.
Their purpose gets hijacked,
overcome by this localized,
really persistent evil.
For me, it's a cautionary tale
of, frankly, total moral ruin.
And I'm arguing that the manner
represents more of a spiritual
catastrophe, sure, but one that
stems from a failure of duty.
The good iconography remains
precisely because it defines the
tragedy.
It's this haunting structure
that explains the specific kind
of Undid we find there, figures
tied to broken oaths, to
vengeance, not just some generic
necromantic evil.
OK, let's dig into the evidence
for collapse, because I think
it's compelling.
Our game, vows told, isn't just
haunted or abandoned, it's
thoroughly ruined.
I mean, the material describes
collapsed towers, furniture
smashed and overturned in the
main halls, graves disturbed
outside this level of physical
destruction, it's not just time
and neglect.
It feels like prima fascia
evidence that active hostile
forces, whether they came from
inside or out, have
fundamentally broken this place,
this sanctuary, and crucially,
the spirits of the nights.
They haven't found peace.
They're called fearsome
adversaries, revenants.
Their spirits just rise again,
seeking revenge, even if they're
struck down.
That points to a malicious,
unending cycle of violence that
seems to completely over shadow
any good they once stood for.
That description of the decay is
certainly vivid, but I guess I
question what the physical state
definitively proves.
Decay and ruin, Well, they're
pretty common across this whole
valley, aren't they?
I approach it differently.
If there were active total
corruption, wouldn't it aim to
eradicate or, you know, replace
the original symbols?
But the core visuals, that
enormous silver dragon, the
morning Lord altar, they are
still prominent features.
They haven't been defaced in the
same way, or torn down, or
replaced with symbols of pure
darkness.
But what about the other things
the party saw?
That fleeting Serpentine shadow
with wings, the loud hissing
they heard right when they
entered, doesn't that suggest an
active, maybe external dark
force has actually taken up
residence?
This entity, even if it was just
a glimpse, it seems like it's
eclipsed whatever good was there
before.
The decay feels too thorough,
too violent for just a
historical haunting, you know?
Maybe.
But let's consider the Knights
themselves.
The material is quite precise
here.
They are revenants driven by
unresolved duty or vengeance,
not mindless zombies.
And we're specifically told they
were found kneeling before the
Morning Lord's altar.
Now that suggests their
connection to that ideal is
deeply corrupted absolutely.
But severed?
I wouldn't go that far.
It feels more like a terrifying,
twisted kind of fidelity.
Their power source is specific.
And remember Traxidor's
reaction?
He was confused momentarily by
this conflict.
The silver dragon champion of
good and these dangerous undead
kneeling before its symbol.
That dissonance.
I think that's the entire point.
It's an internal paradox the
material deliberately presents,
pointing towards a failed
sanctuary, not just some
conquered evil den.
I see why you're emphasizing the
dissonance.
Yeah, but let's focus on the
core behavior, the effect of
their existence.
You mentioned the kneeling, but
what's their function now?
These creatures, the material
notes, they are far more
powerful than whites.
Why?
Because they have this unending
quest for revenge, so they're
kneeling in practice, Isn't it
just an ironic, maybe empty
gesture?
A ritual with no real spiritual
meaning anymore, given their
undead, incredibly violent
state.
Oh, I wouldn't call it empty.
It's performative, maybe, but in
a horrifying way.
It's like this mocking religious
tableau, a visual representation
of what happens when sacred duty
collapses in on itself.
Perhaps, but their primary
function now is violence, pure
hostility towards anyone who
enters.
We saw it immediately with that
savage attack on Radley, right?
That specific, unending violence
focused on preserving their
twisted domain.
Doesn't that override any
symbolic echo of their original
ideals?
The truth of the place now feels
like inescapable malice,
whatever that altar once
represented.
That's a strong point about
their immediate aggression, yes,
but have you really considered
the distinction Urichhorn makes
about their classification?
These aren't, as he says, simple
animated skeletons or just
generic ghosts.
They're heightened power.
They're persistent.
It's intrinsically tied to a
very specific emotional
self-sustaining curse 1 rooted
in betrayal or a failure of
duty.
That's the definition of a
revenant.
If the place were just some
generic evil ruin, why would the
controlling evil force bother
with this highly specific form
of undead?
Why would the Knights retain the
symbols of their old order and
even maintain a physical
position of devotion, kneeling,
even if it's totally perverted?
Their power, it seems, comes
from that broken oath that makes
the location a site of profound
failure, a kind of catastrophic
spiritual stagnation rather than
just total conquest by some
outside corruption.
They're cursed by their own
history, not simply animated
puppets.
But stagnation, when it results
in unending, violent, self
renewing hostility,
functionally, that becomes
corruption, doesn't it?
The revenants will rise again.
They will seek revenge, either
against those who wronged them
ages ago, or just anyone who
enters their space now.
That relentless malice that
feels like the very definition
of a fundamentally tainted
spiritual landscape.
Any connection to the Silver
Dragon is now just fuel for
their vengeance machine.
But I think the type of fuel
matters.
If it were pure external
corruption, wouldn't they just
be shadows, Wraiths.
Something less specific.
The fact that it's fueled by
duty and vengeance, suggests
this element of tragedy.
Something that maybe potentially
could be resolved, however
unlikely.
OK, let's pivot slightly to the
physical evidence again,
interpreting the physical decay,
the sheer state of the place,
smashed furniture, collapsed
towers, the disturbed graves
right outside.
That isn't just weathering.
It feels like tangible proof of
destructive corruption.
The physical ruin mirrors the
spiritual ruin of the knighthood
itself.
The state of the building for me
proves the sanctuary has been
utterly overcome.
I'm sorry, I just don't quite
buy that the physical decay
automatically proves spiritual
conquest.
Ruin happens, especially where
there's been long conflict and
neglect, which perfectly
describes a failed order, right?
If the collapse was proof of
total conquest by some outside
evil, then why did that key
symbol of good, the dragon
statue, seem to retain even a
flicker of, well, active
defense?
I mean, the material describes
that chill air exhaling from the
statue when the party enters.
It didn't harm them, sure, but
it was undeniably there.
I might frame that chill air
differently, maybe just a
lingering echo, an atmospheric
quirk from the intense haunting,
or simply the byproduct of so
much death concentrated there,
not necessarily a lingering
protective charm.
If it were truly protective, why
is the manner overrun with
revenants?
Why is there that weird winged
Serpentine shadow lurking about?
The dominant spiritual feeling
is 1 of unending revenge and
decay, backed up by the
scattered bones and disturbed
graves right next door.
It seems the Knights have taken
their ideals of duty and justice
and twisted them into the
singular pursuit of malice.
But the material presents the
statue as a champion of good.
For it to retain any active
effect, no matter how weak,
suggests that the ideal itself,
the spiritual framework the
silver dragon represents, hasn't
been fully snuffed out.
The decay, I think, is the
result of terrible conflict and
the failure of the Knights to
uphold their oaths.
But the structural symbols of
good, they still retain some
vestige of power, some presence
even amidst the ruin, almost
like a painful reminder of what
was lost.
Their vengeance is certainly a
curse born from who they were, I
grant you that.
But let's think about the
broader implications here for
the materials whole spiritual
landscape.
The real message of Argenvos
told if you see it as total
collapse is, well, it's bleak.
It suggests that even the
strongest champions of good
implied by the Silver dragon,
the Morning Lord, can be
fundamentally hijacked, their
devotion twisted into this
tireless, self fueling engine of
revenge.
That sets a deeply unsettling
precedent for the party's own
quest against straw, doesn't it?
It's like a warning.
Past heroism offers no real
defense against present
persistent corruption.
That bleak?
Why complicate things with
revenants?
If the goal was pure
malevolence, wouldn't they just
be simpler undead like whites or
spectres, stripped of their past
identities?
The fact that they are revenants
makes them tragic reminders that
justice and duty, when they
fail, when they're unmet, it can
curdle into something arguably
worse, a more fearsome curse
than pure, simple malice.
Their very nature suggests that
redemption, or at least
resolution of the curse might be
possible.
Extremely difficult, yes, but
possible because it's tied to a
specific broken oath.
I'm still not quite convinced by
that line of reasoning, mainly
because the Revenant's current
actions, their primary behavior,
is just purely hostile.
It's focused entirely on
violently forcing intruders to
leave this place.
Any connection to the Morning
Lord feels like, well, ancient
history now.
A historical footnote that just
serves as an ironic backdrop for
their current malicious state.
And the presence of that
fleeting Serpentine shadow seems
to confirm the environment is
actively corrupted, likely by an
outside force, completely
overshadowing any faint notion
of failed heroism that could
somehow still be redeemed.
But we have to acknowledge the
dissonance the material presents
all at once.
The specific nature of the
revenants, the enduring silver
dragon statue, the kneeling
posture.
The manner isn't merely evil.
Its identity is wrapped up in
its tragedy.
The failure of their sacred duty
created this uniquely dangerous
and complex siritual mess.
One with the ersistence of the
good symbols only serves to
amplify the horror of their
fall, and suggests maybe that
the real conflict here is
philosophical, not just a matter
of finding and destroying
obvious evil.
Ultimately though, the state of
Argenvoss Holt ruined, occupied
by the self-sustaining hostile
undead, possibly monitored by
some active hostile force.
It really demonstrates, I think,
that the forces of corruption
have fundamentally tainted this
location.
They've reduced powerful ideals
to mere historical artifacts.
The unending self renewing cycle
of the revenants proves that.
Malice and vengeance persist
almost without limit.
It feels like a place truly
conquered by spiritual rot.
While the tragedy the Knights
follow the absolutely
undeniable, the sheer physical
presence of the Silver Dragon
statue and the Morning Lord
altar, the very altar these
revenants still kneel before,
suggests a far more nuanced
story.
This isn't just another evil
layer, it's a monument to
profound failure, and the
specific nature of the undead,
these powerful revenants,
confirms a twisted, complex,
and, yeah, ersistent connection
back to the very ideals they
once chamioned.
Understanding why those symbols
remain is, I think, crucial to
grasping the full complexity of
this setting.
Clearly, the interaction between
those enduring symbols of good
and the powerful, persistent
nature of the revenants at
Argenvoss talt it it definitely
merits deeper exploration within
the material.
It offers a genuinely
challenging look at the nature
of spiritual conflict in this
world.
Absolutely.
And so we leave it to the
listener to weigh the evidence.
Is the manner fundamentally
corrupted?
It's goodness extinguished.
Or is it tragically cursed,
haunted forever by the
catastrophic failure of its
former heroic champions?
Welcome back to the Deep Dive.
Today we are strapping in for
perhaps our most intense
analysis yet, charting a well, a
really high stakes journey.
Absolutely.
It starts with this frantic
escape, moves through a very
controversial resurrection and
ends up at this haunted Manor.
It's quite the sequence.
Yeah, guarded by some kind of,
like, undying fury.
This deep dive, it's really
about the moral calculus of
survival.
You know what's the actual price
of life in this cursed land?
And what kind of enemies do you
make when you mess with the
dead?
That's a big part of it,
definitely.
We're pulling from session 20
and 21 notes here.
They take us right from the
Streets of the Lackey to the
Weirdness of Arjen.
Vols Holt.
OK, So what's the core mission
for us today, right?
It's kind of three things we
need to unpack this shifting
alliance with Van Richt and the
Monster Hunter.
He's complicated then really dig
into the cost spiritual
political of bringing Traxador
back with the Abbot's hell the.
Abbot in Kresk, right?
Always a strange one.
Exactly.
And finally figure out the
nature of these new adversaries
they just ran into.
They seem personalized and
tough.
OK, let's set the scene.
We're starting in Volaki.
The clocks basically hit 0.
Bradley escaped execution, but
Tracidor the cleric not so
lucky.
No, his body was publicly
displayed.
A warning from the new boss,
Lady Watcher.
Grim stuff.
So the party's sneaking around
after dark, trying to get his
body back before they can even
think about leaving town.
It's sheer loyalty, right?
But also desperation.
They know being out after curfew
under Watcher is risky.
But leaving tracidor there
unthinkable for them.
Right.
And the notes say the second
they grabbed the body, boom,
trap sprung.
They walked right into it.
Calculated deadly.
And this wasn't just town
guards.
Lady Watcher showing off her new
power.
She's summoned something nasty.
Yeah, a full-fledged Barb devil.
And you need to understand this
isn't just a minor fiend, it's
large.
It's tough, like infernal shock
troops.
Covered in barbs, fiery attacks,
the works.
Absolutely.
It's presence alone means Hell's
basically opened up shop in
Valaki and wasn't alone.
Several smaller flying ones.
Spiny Devils aerial support.
So chaos, pure chaos in the back
streets, howling fire.
Total cacophony.
Imagine that echoing in those
narrow alleys and they're trying
to escape while carrying a body.
Right.
Bradley's got Traxador.
He's strong, but that's dead
weight slowing them down.
He's literally trudging, the
notes say Dearman's on foot
scrambling euro horns on his
Panther so he's faster.
But the devil's right behind
them.
Relentless and hurling Hellfire
like actual balls of fire.
They're dodging and weaving,
carrying a body.
They.
Can't outrun that.
No way.
Exactly.
The notes suggest they were
getting ready to turn and fight
a last stand.
Suicidal, really.
They felt trapped.
Something changed.
Says they're about to commit.
Yeah.
A figure appears silhouetted in
the mist ahead, walking towards
the chaos.
Walking towards a barbed devil.
Completely unhurried, you just
hear this tap tap sound.
A metal shod walking stick on
the cobblestones.
So calm against the howling.
That's unnerving.
Who is it?
The light hits him.
Your horn recognizes him
instantly.
Rudolf and Richton the Monster
Hunter, the guy who was
disguised as Rectavio the circus
master.
All right, the expert.
And what's interesting is your
horns had big doubts about
Radley and Derman, right?
But seeing this thing, all that
suspicion just vanishes.
Immediate threat.
Trump's everything.
OK, so then Richton arrives.
What does he do?
Does he just wade in?
He drops the casual act
immediately, pulls a thin blade
hidden in the cane, says he'll
handle it.
And Radley.
Radley just keeps jogging past
with the body.
Pure survival instinct, maybe
thinking even Van Richten can't
stop this thing.
OK.
So then, Richten versus the
devil.
And this is where you see his
power.
He casts dispel good and evil.
Big Spell does it with a
flourish.
While the devil's attacking.
Literally lunging at him inches
away.
The party's watching, probably
expecting him to get torn apart.
A pulse of blue light shimmers
out.
The Devil's Roar just stops,
cuts off mid howl, it recoils,
and then poof.
Gone.
Not killed, banished, erased
from this plane.
Instantaneous.
Wow, OK, the silence after that
must have been intense.
Overwhelming, I bet.
And then classic Van Richton
sheets.
The blade turns to the heroes,
who are still sort of shuffling
away.
He congratulates them.
Not quite.
He says something like he wasn't
actually sure that spell would
work.
Seldom any guarantees with magic
of that kind, he mutters.
Always the pragmatist.
OK.
And then he snaps it.
Radley calls him an O for just
trundling off with the body,
tells him to come back and
listen.
Huh.
OK, so respect for courage
maybe, but not for inefficiency.
That sounds like him.
That's the dynamic right there.
So the party explains their
plan.
Get to the blue water in, grab
their wagon, head to Kresk.
Hope the Abbot can do a
resurrection.
What's then Richton's take on
the resurrection part?
He gives this like skeptical
look when they mention the Abbot
but his main focus is tactical.
He says no you can't go back to
the end, why not?
He figures anyone summoning
devils like Watcher probably has
smaller invisible spies, little
Imps or something watching.
So going back with lead Watcher
straight to Danica and Irwin at
the end.
Exactly.
Endanger them directly.
His paranoia, or maybe just
baredness, saves the Martakoffs.
OK.
And you mentioned a slip up.
Yeah, right here.
While they're talking about
protecting allies Yurihorn
accidentally, let's slip
something about the Martakoffs
being were Ravens.
Oops to Van Richten, the master
Monster Hunter.
He was completely unaware, the
notes say.
Van Richten gives Yurihorn this
really sharp, curious look, puts
the Ranger on the spot.
How does Yurihorn handle it?
Quick backtrack, gives a vague
dismissive answer, tries to
cover it up.
Does Van Richten push?
No, wisely, he lets it go, but
it hangs there.
You know this unspoken thing.
They're allies of convenience,
not total trust.
Critical truths are still being
hidden.
So no in where do they go?
Van Richten takes them to the
Air 6 stockyard.
That's where his ride is parked.
He's right.
A battered old carnival wagon.
Peel and paint, says Rick
Tavio's Carnival of Wonders on
the side.
Kind of ironic now.
OK, a wagon escape vehicle.
But he gives him a very clear
warning.
Don't touch the padlock back
door.
Don't even try.
More secrets?
Didn't he have issues with your
horns Panther earlier?
He did, and now as they get
close to this wagon, the Panther
gets edgy.
Low growl, tail straight, ears
flat.
Classic predator sensing another
predator.
And then the wagon lurches
violently.
Something big and heavy shifts
inside.
Another animal.
Definitely sounds like another
large cat secured in the back.
Yeah.
So Van Richten isn't just a
hunter.
He's maybe transporting
dangerous creatures.
It has a whole new layer to him.
He's prepared for anything.
OK, so they need to get out of a
lackey fast.
How does that go?
Well, Van Richten hitches his
horse.
Derman quickly ties Traxidor's
body wrapped up to the back
stoop of the wagon.
Then Van Richten just snaps the
reins, charges the horse full
tilt.
At the southern gate, guards are
yelling halt.
He ignores them completely.
Does he make it?
Sort of.
The wooden bar across the gate
snaps, yeah, but the front wheel
hits the brick archway hard.
Oh, no.
Instant disaster.
Axle shatters the wheel just
shears right off the wagon,
skids maybe 50 feet past the
gate and grinds to a halt,
digging into the dirt.
So they're out but stuck.
Right outside the gate, pinned
down. 3 guards in a warden rush
out.
The warden starts firing off
necromantic magic bolts.
Bad situation.
Can they freak back?
Dearman and your horn.
Use their bows, take down to
guards quickly, but the third
one gets a horn.
Call off.
Alarm is sounded.
Reinforcements are coming.
They've got minutes, maybe less.
What about the wagon?
Can they?
Fix it.
This part is almost.
Comical but desperate, Van
Richten is yelling for the
wheel.
Derman grabs it.
Radley, using all his eldritch
night strength with Derman
helping, actually lifts the
broken corner of the wagon off
the ground.
He lifts the wagon.
Trying to hold it up so van.
Richten can get the wheel back
on but it's useless.
The axle linkage is totally
smashed, wood and metal
splintered.
No way to fix it normally, so
they are trapped.
It looks that way.
Hearts must have sunk, but Van
Richten pulls out another trick.
He casts mending, bending the.
Cantrip, yeah, see basic, right?
But he uses it perfectly on the
shattered axle linkage.
The magic just knits the wood
and metal back together,
instantly functional again.
That's incredible.
Saved.
By a magical first aid on a
wagon wheel.
Kind of perfect for Borovia.
Isn't it?
They scramble back on board,
leave the guards shouting in the
dust, and head W towards Kresk,
finally free of A.
Lackey What about Van Richten?
Does he stick with them only
through the night?
As morning approaches near
Kresk, he just leaves.
Says he needs to find a new
place to finish his plans.
Rides off into the mists.
So helpful when?
Needed, but ultimately a lone
wolf.
Exactly.
He.
Helped them survive, but now
they're on their own again,
facing the Abbey.
OK, so they.
Arrive at the Abbey of Saint
Markovia.
What's the vibe?
Is it welcoming?
Not really.
It's stark, high on a hill,
chilly, snow on the ground,
forbidding.
The Cres Town guards let them
in.
They know the party by now.
But the Abbey itself, problems
start right away at the gate,
Yeah.
The Mongrel.
Folk guards Zig Frick and Otto
found them asleep at their post
Classic.
Oh boy.
And when they wake up, there's
this immediate argument, not
about the party getting in, but
about your horn's Panther.
They won't let the beast on the
holy ground.
Petty stuff when they've just.
Escaped death and are carrying a
corpse totally so.
Derman, thinking fast, realizes
arguing is pointless.
He needs leverage.
What does he do?
Demands they fetch.
Their master, the Abbot, and the
excuse he says they have that
wedding dress the Abbot wanted
for Vassilka, his creation, the
dress.
Does that work like magic?
The Abbot comes rushing out,
absolutely beaming, laughing,
holding up this crumpled, muddy
dress like it's the holiest
relic imaginable.
Doesn't care that it's filthy.
Not one bit.
He immediately invites them all
in, Panther included.
The Mongol folk are clearly
disgusted, but the dress Trump's
everything.
For the Abbot, it's key to his
big plan.
OK, so they're inside.
They've got Tracer's body.
This is the moment of truth.
They ask for the resurrection.
They demand it really carry.
The body in the Abbot initially
just offers, you know, a proper
burial, standard stuff, but they
push him, yeah.
And his mood.
Shifts.
The notes mention a flash of
real anger before he kind of
smooths it over.
Does he refuse He.
Argues against it.
First, surprisingly, he gives
this little speech about the
purposeful cycle of life and
death and the dangers of
tampering, the risk of
unforeseen calamity.
So he knows it's.
Risky.
He understands the implications.
He absolutely.
Does He's not naive about what
he's doing bringing a soul back.
He knows the power and the
potential cost.
And yet.
He agrees abruptly.
Yes.
And this is the core issue in
Krusk, isn't it?
Why does he do it after arguing
against it?
The dress purely.
The dress.
It's transactional.
Bringing tracks that are back
isn't about compassion or
rewarding a good cleric.
It's payment for the item that
helps his ultimate, frankly
bizarre mission, redeeming Strad
to.
Make Barovia a paradise again
using the silk, the flesh golem
bride.
Yeah, yeah, OK.
Right.
So this profound miracle
restoring life is just currency
for his political, theological
end game.
It's kind of chilling.
So he agrees, tells them it'll.
Take time.
They come back the next morning.
Day 16.
Yeah, they go.
Back down and tracks doors alive
just like that fully.
Alive, yes.
But the cost is visible.
He's in a simple monk's robe,
wooden holy symbol of the
Morning Lord.
But he looks drained.
How so?
Utterly.
Fatigued.
The notes say he struggles just
to stand up.
His voice is soft, weak.
What's the Abbot's?
Explanation.
He calls it the soul's.
Arduous journey back to the body
says he just needs a few days to
recover but it's clear right
there resurrection isn't
flicking a switch.
The soul went through something
traumatic to get back.
Wow.
But the.
Real emotional fallout happens
later, right?
With the Burgo mask?
Oh yeah, before.
Leaving Kresk, they need gear
for Traxxidor.
They go see Baron Dmitry
Kreskov, the Burgo master, and
he sees Traxidor.
Alive and he just loses it.
Completely distraught, rushes
out, grabs Traxidor, shaking
him, furious, demanding to know
what trickery this is because
he'd been told the cleric was
dead.
He didn't know the Abbot could.
Do this or wouldn't exactly the?
Realization that the Abbott has
this power, used it for
strangers but not for Kresk's
own people.
It breaks him.
What does he do?
Sinks to his knees in the
street, weeping, shouting, the
notes quote him, yelling.
Why should Ilya, the last of the
Kreskov line, die when the
Abbott can return my son to me?
Oh man, that's.
Heartbreaking.
His son died and the Abbot could
have saved him.
That's the implication.
And the Abbot chose not to or
couldn't be persuaded.
His grand plan for Straud took
precedence over the very real
grief of the town's leader, the
potential end of a noble line.
It's the ultimate condemnation
of the abbot's priorities.
So the Abbot's paradise.
Comes at the cost of individual
suffering.
Right now, pretty much his.
Wife Anna Kreskova has to pull
the Baron back inside.
But the guards, they see the
injustice.
They quietly give Traxador some
basic gear.
Studded leather, spear, Mace,
shield, backpack, water, skin.
Minimal stuff, but a gesture.
OK, so Traxador is.
Back minimally equipped, they
leave Kresk.
What's the plan now?
Priority shifts they need.
To retrieve that stolen holy
amulet, Madame Eva told them
about the one they need to
eventually face straw.
Strategic necessity, right?
The artifact hunt.
They head east on the old
Swellidge Rd.
Yep, and.
As they're traveling, discussing
this amulet, something weird
happens.
Atmospheric.
You got it.
A cauldron.
Of bats, the notes call it
suddenly bursts overhead.
Not just a few bats, A massive
swarm moving together like 1
entity.
A murmuration.
Whoa, what do they do?
It sweeps down low.
Right over the road engulfs the
party for a second in this like
silent swirling cloud of black
wings, and then just as quickly,
it flies off into the mists
ahead near the lunar river
bridge.
OK, that's creepy.
An omen feels like it, right?
Dense, sudden, deliberate, like
a warning about where they're
heading.
So where are they heading?
They turn off the main Rd.
Following info van Richten gave
them back when he was Rectavio
about an old Manor house.
And they find it.
Yeah.
The path leads.
Up onto this rise and there it
is, Argon, Voss told huge,
decrepit Manor overlooking the
Lunar River Valley, Mount Gakis
looming in the background.
It looks ancient and sad.
Argon boss hold.
OK, what?
Stands out first the most
striking thing.
Right out front, a big statue on
a 10 foot stone base.
A silver dragon.
But aren't they good exactly
tracidor?
Points that out immediately.
Silver Dragons are champions of
good protectors.
It's a symbol of light guarding
this gloomy ruin place.
Very odd.
You're a horn, checks the base.
No mechanisms, no inscriptions.
So a noble symbol.
In front of a wreck.
What's the rest of the place
look like?
Decay.
Collapse towers and walls on one
side, an old barn foundation,
and, significantly, a tall
mausoleum and a graveyard off to
the east.
Graveyard let me.
Guess disturbed graves.
Bingo.
A number.
Of them suggests old battles,
maybe grave robbing.
Definitely disrespect for the
dead.
OK, so they head for the main.
Entrance up the stairs.
The name Arginvostolt is carved
right into the stone lentil
above the door, and as they step
inside, something happens.
A blast of cold air.
Washes over them, seems to come
from the dragon statue outside.
Weirdly doesn't hurt them, but
it feels like a warning, like
the place itself is reacting.
Spooky.
What's the foyer?
Like grand but.
Faded stone pillars, big
staircase, balcony.
There's a tapestry showing a
knight in shining armor, hints
of a noble military past.
Any immediate threats?
Not immediately.
Radley uses his shield to cast
light, and that's when it
happens.
A loud hissing sound echoes
through the hall, and then,
quick as anything, a shadow
falls across the wall.
A shadow of.
What a Serpentine.
With wings like a dragon, but
just a shadow.
It flashes past.
The hissing stops.
Silence again.
The serpent shadow.
OK.
That ramps up the creep factor.
Draconic, but not quite exactly
it's.
Just the forces here are
ancient, maybe related to
Dragons but maybe twisted.
Where do they go next?
Deeper in.
Find a dining hall.
Big 20 foot table but furniture
is smashed.
Overturn signs of violence or
looting.
Anything else significant?
The chairs, the.
One still standing have backs
carved to look like folded
dragon wings.
Golden dragon wings so.
Whoever lived here, they were
definitely connected to Dragons.
Knights of the dragon maybe?
Seems very likely.
Every detail points to this
dragon motif.
Then they find leaded glass
doors leading to the Chapel.
Ah, the Chapel.
What's in there?
This is where the paradox really
hits you.
Tall arched windows, stained
glass, and kneeling at the
altar. 3 figures in rusted
chainmail.
Undead look like it, but the
altar itself?
It has a carving of a rising
sun, the symbol of the morning.
Lord, the good deity.
Exactly.
So you have these.
Potentially undead nights
kneeling before the symbol of a
God of light and life.
It makes no sense.
OK, that is seriously.
Confusing good symbols?
Undead guardians, What does the
party do?
Does your horn sense anything?
He uses his primordial.
Sense yeah confirms there's a
lot of undead energy around the
Manor grounds but and this is
key no actual Dragons nearby
yeah living or undead within a
mile at least so whatever these
nights are they're.
Not Dragons themselves.
What are they?
That's the question.
It's a total.
Psychological trap?
Do you attack what look like
undead monsters who are praying
to a good God?
Tricky.
Who makes the 1st?
Move Dermot.
Always the curious one.
Maybe a bit reckless.
Uses mage hand, The invisible
magic hand.
Oh no, don't tell me he.
Poked 1.
He tapped one on the shoulder.
Gently bad idea.
Very bad idea.
All three figures stir, rise
slowly, deliberately turn
towards the party.
What do they say?
Simple.
Question.
Why do you disturb the dead?
Then they draw these tarnished
long swords and tell the party
to leave now.
OK, definitely hostile.
How do they look?
Just skeletons.
You're a horn.
Realizes instantly watching them
move in that heavy armor.
These are way tougher than basic
skeletons, not even whites.
Something more powerful, elite
undead warriors and combat
starts.
Immediately.
Radley steps up, tries to engage
one by some time, casts shield
as the first blow comes.
How does it work?
Perry's the first hit, yeah, but
the second blow from the night
lands hard, savagely jars Radley
right through the magical
shield, forces him stumbling
back.
Wow.
So these.
Things hit like trucks, immense
power.
The notes really emphasize that
it's immediately clear the party
is seriously outmatched here.
How does Trexidor react?
He was just resurrected, sees
undead at an altar of his God.
Total spiritual crisis.
He summons his spiritual weapon,
this glowing divine hammer
thing, but he hesitates.
He can't reconcile it.
The contradiction.
Undead Nights Morning Lord's
symbol?
Exactly.
Are they corrupted?
Are they holy guardians?
Attacking feels wrong, but
letting them attack feels worse.
His divine sense is just
scrambled by the paradox, so he
doesn't attack not.
Directly with the weapon.
He tries using his channel
divinity instead to rebuke
undead.
See if that works.
Does it partially.
One of the nights actually
recoils, backs off a step.
So they are vulnerable to holy
power, but only one.
What about the other two?
They keep pressing the.
Attack relentless.
Dearman tries a distraction, a
minor illusion behind them, but
they don't even seem to notice,
totally focused on driving the
intruders out.
So rebuke works A.
Bit illusion fails.
They're still losing badly.
It's.
Clear This is not a winnable
fight right now.
They're forced into a fighting
retreat, backing out, swords
flashing through the FOIA past
the dragon statue.
Right past it, out the front.
Doors into the open air, the
Knights pursue them right to the
threshold, then stop.
Safe outside for.
Now adrenaline crash.
I bet totally.
And that's.
When your horn puts it together.
He's the monster expert, after
all.
He thinks about how they fought,
their power, their single
mindedness, and he figures out
what they.
Are yeah, he.
Delivers the bad news.
Those weren't just tough undead,
they were revenants.
Revenants.
OK, how?
Bad.
Is that really bad?
This changes everything.
Your horn explains it to the
others.
Revenants aren't just animated
corpses, they're driven by this
powerful, undying spirit of
vengeance.
A specific grudge or hatred
fuels them, so they're
intelligent.
And motivated.
Highly motivated.
Incredibly.
Resilient, but the worst part?
Their spirits don't rest,
meaning even if you destroy
their current body, the spirit
doesn't pass on.
It finds the nearest suitable
corpse, possesses it, rises
again, and comes right back
after you, still driven by that
same original vengeance.
Oh wow, so defeating.
Them physically is temporary at
best, unless you can resolve
the.
Reason for their vengeance?
Yeah, they're basically just
activated.
An eternal enemy, Personalized,
undying, Relentless.
All from tapping one on the
shoulder.
They didn't just fight some.
Monsters.
They picked a fight with ghosts
that won't stay dead.
Hashtag tag outro.
OK, let's let's try and wrap our
heads around all that.
What a journey.
The physical escape from Falaki
dodging Hellfire Van Richten's
magic, right?
The banishment was impressive.
But then being saved by mending
on a wagon wheel?
Almost anticlimactic, but
totally crucial.
Then the whole Kresk.
Situation Trexors return, but
the cost, yeah, that
resurrection.
Reveals so much about the Abbot.
His goal.
Redeeming straw Trump's
everything.
Individual life, the grief of
Baron Kreskov, the principles of
life and death, all secondary to
his grand, flawed plan.
Traxidor's life was just
payment, not a gift.
A.
Transaction and then Arjen Vos
told This place is just layers
of contradiction.
Exactly.
You've got the goodness.
Of the silver dragon symbol, the
Morning Lord's altar, right next
to these powerful, seemingly
corrupt undying nights.
Faith, decay, duty, vengeance.
All tangled up.
And that first fight just
proves.
How dangerous it is, the search
for that amulet, it's not going
to be easy, not at all.
They're.
Facing revenants now, that's not
just a combat challenge, it's a
persistent threat.
These spirits are motivated,
they're relentless, and they
will keep coming back.
That tap on the shoulder started
something potentially unending.
So we saw a soul.
Come back from what the Abbot
called an arduous journey,
clearly fatigued by it.
And now we've met creatures
whose spirits seemingly never
leave, they just find new bodies
to continue their hate.
A real contrast.
In how souls interact with this
world, isn't it?
Definitely.
So if Van Richten himself says
magic has seldom any guarantees,
what are the real long term
costs US for Traxador soul after
that transactional resurrection?
And what kind of ancient
powerful vengeance have they
truly woken up inside Arjun
Bosstholt halls?
Yeah, what is eternal?
Undeath driven by vengeance look
like when it's focused squarely
on you.
Something to think about.
Welcome back.
Today we're looking at a piece
covering a pretty intense
escape, a resurrection bargain,
and a scary showdown with some
undead nights.
Yeah, lots.
Happening.
So let's dive right in.
Try and make these big moments
hit even harder.
OK, first.
Up.
That.
Escape from Valaki.
Rudolf Van Richten's appearance
is, while stunning, great drama,
but the way he takes out the
barbed Devil one spell, it feels
like it kind of short circuits
the tension they'd built.
It really does, I mean.
The material did a good job
setting up this devil.
Relentless throwing Hellfire.
Exactly.
The party couldn't outrun it.
You felt that desperation.
Radley's exhausted, carrying the
body.
It felt like they.
Were properly cornered and then
Van Richten steps in, casts
dispel good and evil and problem
solved instantly.
Yeah, instantly.
And even that line about the
thunderous silence afterwards?
It's dramatic, sure, but the
threat just evaporates.
Hmm.
It makes the devil.
Seem, I don't know, less
formidable after the fact?
Like, was it really that big a
threat if one spell could just
dismiss it?
Right, so the.
Weakness is that imbalance.
The relief is huge, but the
resolution feels almost too
easy.
No real cost felt in that
moment.
So the suggestion.
Is really about recentering that
confrontation?
Van Richten needs to be crucial,
Absolutely.
But maybe not the instant win
button.
Yeah, we need to.
Reinforce how tough these
infernal things are.
Make the survival feel earned,
You know, not just convenient.
I think you've nailed it.
The intervention needs a clearer
cost, otherwise, like you said,
it feels less like a climax and
more like, well, a plot device
just wiping the slate clean.
So how do we do that?
Maybe, maybe the spell doesn't
banish it completely.
Ah, I like.
That what if the dispel good and
evil works but it's say just
severely wounds the devil or
stuns it right then Van.
Richten in the party have to
scramble, work together for
another round or two, a fighting
retreat kind of thing.
Keeps that tension.
High right at the escape point
forces them to rely on each
other under fire.
That could work really well.
Or maybe the?
Cost is more personal to Van
Richten.
How so?
Well, the text.
Mentions him saying he was
unsure that it was going to
work.
What if we show that risk?
Describe him as visibly drained,
maybe even injured because he
cast such a powerful, risky
spell.
Oh, interesting.
So he pays a price for the
intervention.
Maybe he's like coughing,
weakened.
Yeah, maybe.
The spell takes a serious toll
that would add weight to his
uncertainty, and it would
justify why he needs to get out
of Locky immediately too.
It feeds into his character
later.
I see so.
The immediate threat is handled,
but there's a lingering
consequence, a cost that feels
much stronger narratively.
Yeah, it shifts it.
From few they got lucky to wow
that was close and it cost them
something more earned.
Agreed.
Definitely more earned.
OK, let's shift.
Gears the Abbot of Kresk and
tracks the doors.
Resurrection.
We need to strengthen the logic
behind the Abbott's big decision
here.
It feels abrupt.
Yeah, the motivation.
Shift is the tricky part.
It's not that he can't be
unhinged, his logic just needs
to be, well, logical within its
own framework, the material
sets.
Up his initial stance, really.
Clearly he's angry, right?
Philosophically opposed to
messing with life and death,
talks about the risks, divine
wrath, all that.
Exactly.
It's presented as a major moral
and spiritual boundary for him,
but then the.
Party shows up with this
crumpled and muddy dress and
suddenly all.
Those profound objections just
vanish.
He agrees to perform this huge
reality altering act
resurrection, basically as a
reward for fetching an item for
his creepy doll project, right?
And.
While OK, the text mentions his
bigger goal of redeeming Strad,
the direct trigger, the dress
feels disproportionate, almost
trivial compared to bringing
someone back from the dead.
That's the core weakness.
That disconnect, it feels
transactional in a way that
undermines the gravity of both
his initial refusal and the act
of resurrection itself.
So the suggestion.
Is to layer his decision making,
make it less like quest item for
reward and more like a a a
believable step in his own
messed up plan.
Or really lean into how skewed
his priorities are we need to
make.
That.
Dress mean something more to him
in that moment connected to his
grander, albeit insane, purpose
make the retrieval of.
The dress the important thing,
not the dress itself.
Precisely.
For example, maybe the Abbot
explicitly says something like
the party bringing back the
stress against all odds proves
their devotion, their
commitment.
Ah, so retrieving.
The dress becomes proof they
understand sacrifice, proof
there may be worthy allies and
his impossible quest to fix
Strad exactly.
It overrides his spiritual
concerns because he sees it as
evidence they're truly committed
to his cause.
It reframes his madness as a
kind of twisted test of faith
that could work.
It ties the.
Seemingly trivial task to his
core obsession.
What about linking the dress to
the ritual itself?
How do you mean?
Well, tracidor comes.
Back fatigued, right?
What if that's not just a random
side effect?
What if the Abbot needs the
party's help with the ritual?
And maybe the dress is, I don't
know, an ingredients or an
anchor, so.
The dress isn't just the price
for the resurrection, it's part
of the process, and maybe
involving the party or using
this mundane item is why it's
flawed.
Why Tracksidar comes back
weekend.
Yeah, it.
Makes the consequence feel less
arbitrary.
It links the fetch quest, the
resurrection and the characters
resulting stayed together in a
more meaningful and kind of dark
way.
I like that it.
Adds a layer of consequence tied
directly to the bargain they
made.
Makes the Abbott's method seem
even more suspect too.
OK, good.
Now the final point.
Argon Vest hold maximizing the
terror of those revenants.
Ah yes, the.
Undead nuts.
The action is good, but the big
reveal about what they are it it
comes a bit late.
Yeah, that detail.
That even if you defeat them,
their spirits just find another
corpse and keep coming.
That's chilling.
Super chilling.
But the text holds it back until
the parties basically already
decided they're outmatched and
are retreating, and that's the
weakness.
If they knew from the start that
killing these things was
pointless, that retreat wouldn't
feel like a tactical withdrawal,
it'd feel like pure, desperate
panic.
Exactly.
The reveal comes almost like in
footnote after the main tension
of the fight is established
based on just being outnumbered.
It limits that feeling of
hopelessness, the psychological
horror of it.
We need to get that dread.
In earlier, make the nature of
the revenants clear right away,
so the stakes are immediately
psychological, not just
physical.
Turn it from can.
We beat them to oh God, we can't
beat them.
We need to get out now, right
So.
How to see that earlier?
Well, think about that.
Moment when Derman uses Mage
hand to tap the skeleton
shoulder that initial contact
instead of just startling it.
What if it speaks not just a
groan, but a clear cold word
like vengeance or unfinished?
Something that signals purpose,
not just animation.
Oh, OK.
That immediately changes the
vibe.
You're not just dealing with
animated bones, you're dealing
with an undying will.
Precisely.
Or focus on the combat
descriptions right at the start,
when Radley gets hit hard.
Maybe it's not just the force,
but a palpable sense of focused
hate, like personal burning
hatred radiating from the night.
And maybe they.
See one get struck down, only
for the light in its eyes to
flare brighter, or for it to
start reforming almost
immediately.
Something visually unsettling?
Yes, something.
That forces Yurihorn or someone
to recognize them as revenants
much earlier.
That realization these things
literally cannot be stopped
needs to hit them mid fight, not
afterwards.
So that.
Triggers the desperate escape
attempt not just because they're
losing, but because they realize
victory is impossible against
this enemy.
Exactly.
It transforms the fight into a
frantic flight from an
unkillable curse that ramps up
the readers anxiety immediately
because they understand the true
stakes alongside the characters.
Much more terrifying.
Yeah, that lands.
Much harder.
OK.
I think those are three really
solid areas for enhancement.
The core material has great
dramatic instincts already.
Absolutely.
It's strong stuff.
These are just ways to tighten
the screws, make those big
moments pay off even more so
just to.
Recap the main suggestions.
First, give the Barb Devil
resolution more weight.
Either make Van Richten pay a
price for his spell or force the
party and him to fight a bit
longer together.
Second Shore.
Up the Abbott's logic connect to
the dress retrieval, to his
twisted need for proof of the
party's devotion to his grand
plan, maybe even weaving the
dress into the resurrection
ritual itself to explain the
consequences and 3rd front.
Load the horror of the revenants
make their undying nature clear
much earlier in the
Argenvostholt encounter to
maximize that dread in
desperation.
Yeah, focus on that.
Narrative cost and consequence,
and making sure the reader
understands the stakes right
when the characters do the
action.
Writing is already effective.
These tweaks just sharpen the
impact.
Great insights.
This piece is definitely.
On the right.
Track We absolutely encourage
you to revise and send the
updated material back for
another look.